Albert Breer on the phone right now
senior NFL reporter at the mm QB former
coworker at NFL Network also works with
NBC Sports Boston and what else Breer I
mean there's a long laundry list of jobs
you have right now yeah yeah I figure if
you have a hard time keeping multiple
right like so a whole bunch of different
places how are you doing
a great man it's been a it's been a long
time I'm enjoying reading your stuff as
I always have
I want to get the Patriots question out
of the way right off the top I know you
live in Boston you're a big-time media
personality in the Boston area what's
the reaction locally there to this
latest scandal for lack of a better word
I say noise probably the best I mean I
don't want people here have been through
this before obviously and I think you
know sort of this feeling of what the
hell were they doing like and I would
sort of like a parrot people can't get
away with right like so you know I say
like you know a scandal as I see you
know Coates was taking a recruit out
well that comes probably shouldn't take
that recruit so I a car dealership right
and that anymore the patient's can't be
caught doing anything that like what's
weird
where there's a camera right I just
can't have it happen and so you know I
every indication I've got news that
there was you know no involvement here
on the part of Bill Belichick or anyone
else football ops sloppy you know and
the fact that this brings back you know
a lot of bad memories for people up here
I think that it's just more than
anything else is going so over that well
I would say it son patriot like when you
call it sloppy some other people would
say it's it's very patriot like
considering some of the things that have
happened in the past
I don't believe it Belichick had any
idea what was going on he had much more
important things to worry about than a
do your job feature that the video
apartment was was shooting on one of the
scouts but whoever was running that
department obviously should have had I
think a little more awareness Roger
Goodell says the NFL is investigating
III think it's probably much ado about
nothing but because it's attached to the
Patriots given their history it's hard
to say that at this point correct sure
and you know I think it's now a big part
of this is gonna be what's on that video
on the eight minutes a video on and I'm
so part of that is and look on there at
least is putting other toggles between
players and coaches and that could
create a little bit of a tough on even
if it was completely innocent and even
if a guy who is operating the camera has
no clue what he is doing and so you know
my daddy and the reasons and everything
else they're going to have to do
something and you know the fact that I
was doing everything else I would guess
it'd be a fairly substantial fine that
will come at the end of this you know
again I think that people are inclined
to believe that once I can believe the
Patriots side of the story when the
matter is if third-party the team's
coming into a stadium as a third-party
and again they're not involved with the
camera and there's an advanced area I
assume you just can't have happen and so
I don't know what they're gonna come
down on the patientís president you know
to some degree they're gonna have to
come down Patriots cash punishment
solely do you anticipate it could be a
loss of draft picks anything harsher
yeah we've seen draft picks in the past
I would I would learn anything out of me
is you know we've seen this we've seen
this over the course of this season
actually in particular where you know
they'll find teams and they find
individuals too and we saw in a couple
of the of the internal reporting
situations where you know the Steelers
got you know caught
kind of messing with the injury report
on Ben Roethlisberger and Mike Tomlin
and Kevin Kohlberg got fines and the
lines got you know got in trouble for
the
reporting on Matt's Africa injury and
Bob Oakland and that participate signs
so what will be really interesting here
to me is a lithographic traffic away and
then B it's do they find bill you know
because you know we've seen that last
couple of his cases where lovers having
up football operations takes a little
bit of a hit for it and if we do you
know then of course like that I thought
my guess is that still would be happy
with the clinic you think in the past
you know that they can last were you
down at the league meeting in Texas
Albert I was yeah so in terms of what
came out of there this week your biggest
takeaway was it the fact that the
officiating is gonna be reviewed you
know from the top down was it the new
CBA and the progress that's being made
there what was the biggest takeaway for
you yeah and I'll give you your even
unless there's a little nugget that's
gonna be my column gonna go up here in
the next hour so you know you only
actually sit out in the in the meeting
on Wednesday and said to the group we
need to change the paradigm and Cohen
for a complete overhaul or at least a
deep dive into the officiating in the
wind and I've seen as a attack on the
officiating department or our Iran is it
Warren's doing this whole thing the
wrong way and we in the next three
months basically looking at everything
that we do and then how the game is
associated and reconvene at March the
league reading and discuss how we can
change this and I mean Danny was talking
about things you know it's not just the
new process past if there's all stuff
we've talked about I mean he's talking
about evaluating like we really need to
be calling penalties that are away from
the play I was screwing up the way the
games presented because of the way that
we call the game how come we're okay
with the fact that so many games a story
coming out of the game is the
officiating and so you know where is
I don't have meaning and basics calls
for all the owners to consider
overhauling the officiating system and
changing the paradigm without football
games are assisted so completely like
that'll run looking the number one take
ladies I think if something that's going
to last into the offseason and something
I think that they won't be discussing in
March as the CBA no indication I've
gotten on that is this is sort of
chucking on at this point and no news at
this point is good news that they keep
kind of they keep meeting and then
things haven't broken off and they keep
sort of working at it and you know I
still another clone antenna is a lot
better than it was ten years ago you
know I had a 2011 lockout and you know
they don't come to agreement on the big
stuff the stuff like 70 games but they
are trying to work towards you know
finding a way to at least make the
resolution possible before the NFLPA
owners changes apart
Albert who's coaching the Cowboys next
year I think it would be Lincoln Riley
you know I they've got to know him so
there's a relationship there
and they I know they have a great
affinity for us based on how the
recruitment of John Steven Jones who
Stevenson at Jerry's grandson how how
that how that all limits you know I know
the Jones track down to Riley and watch
tape with them and so there's there's a
great affection there there's me there's
an aberration from the Lincoln sees the
game a little bit differently there's
other people and I think the coaching
sense is going to sort of Center on two
things gonna be one to be passed
successive prominence of the coast and
two is gonna be the development of dak
Prescott and Lincoln rally sucks both
those boxes now Lincoln for his part I
think and I know you told him to a vital
international title at Oklahoma before
he considers leaving but I mean if we're
being real about this I mean the kids
the guy's a native Texan and I think
it'd be really really hard to say no to
cowboy so I think we're gonna Rob you
talk to the OLS I do admire interest is
real and if it's neither of those two
that I
take something up a little bit alright
so either Lincoln Riley or Urban Meyer
as you know there's five to seven head
coaching jobs that are available every
year we have Washington and Carolina
already up Dallas New York Giants
probable Jacksonville Detroit possible
right so when you look at the list right
potential head coaches out there I
believe Ron Rivera is gonna land
somewhere I think Mike McCarthy after a
year off not landing a job last year
will probably be a head coach somewhere
but beyond that you have Matt rule in
college you have David Shaw from
Stanford who's a hot candidate every
single year and I believe Shaw is gonna
wait for the absolute perfect situation
not just with the team but but in life
because he realizes that he has a great
situation in Palo Alto and when he does
leave he could be fired after four years
in the NFL so he wants to make sure he's
done everything at the college level he
possibly can but what about other guys
like Robert Shaw Saleh or Greg Roman
yeah I feel like you don't hear Greg
Romans name enough from what he's
accomplished with Lamar impressive yeah
I would I would actually like I would
point suppose the coordinators in
Baltimore like wink Martindale has done
a great job on defense and they weren't
very good at the beginning you're not
the standard only and he's done a great
job of helping evolve it so I think both
the coordinators at Baltimore Greg Roman
and weak Bart Dale deserve look I also
seem to have openings this year I think
you'll see them sort of like broadening
the search a little bit and the reason
why Dan I like everything's been fishing
off the same pier for a while you know
what I mean like I'm looking for like
the hot young offensive fine and so you
know I think that if you're looking for
that the ranks if it displeased to some
degree and so I do think I see some
teams saying okay well we gotta look
elsewhere it's something that does offer
open opportunity for defensive guys you
mentioned Robert Sawa Dennis Allen and
dowon's has done a fantastic job he
could be in line for a second shot I
mentioned when quire Dale Christmas are
in Dallas you know I bet the college
coaches I think are going to get a look
and
and one thing this sort of interesting
here I think Kliff Kingsbury Swiss by
putting together a competent NFL
operation year one where a lot of people
were sort of waiting for him to sail
they haven't been bad at all you know
like the records not good but they've
been competitive week to week right and
it looks like cliff has an idea of what
he's doing you know I think that there
are going to be this could be the year
where you see more teams trying to go
and get guys out of the college level so
you mentioned that rule I think he was
going to be in demand I know teams that
have openings even a couple that don't
yet have already sort of put feelers out
to him Lincoln Riley I think it's one of
the NFL's white whale but beyond those
guys you know there are more you know
guys like Matt Campbell and Iowa State
like guys are the real program builders
you know people gonna call Ohio State
about Ryan Day I don't think he leaves
but I think that he will get interest
you know I think there is a feeling now
that you know these teams have to look
elsewhere
after tapping that you know that well
general offensive folks for so long and
so I think that that could work to the
benefit of both defensive coaches in the
NFL and these guys who have reputations
as program builders or college level pj
flex not going to be rowing his boat in
the NFL right does that does that that
was worth well I always feel like with
him it takes you a minute to buy in can
you imagine him walking into a team room
and you're a player and you know this
how animated he is and it's he said yeah
he's the CEO of a big company that that
is paid to come there in there and give
pep talks and it's obviously worked at
Minnesota has been a good season for
them I mean hey he's won multiple places
and I won't say this to on the alarmists
about reaching the younger generation to
keeping them engaged and you know
Lucky's really proven to be able to do
that with 18 to 23 years I understand
dealing with current men and everything
else but you know what like I to me like
and you've been around the league a long
time dan this is like all this stuff is
result service and so if you guys who
can succeed as a team and succeed
individually which ultimately she was in
a chance to make a lot of money they're
gonna listen to you you know and so all
these stories things like all these guys
come in sort of different packages if PJ
flag had come into a place knowing
quickly I I don't know why we call
couples down to that whether or not he
can give the guys the answers to the
class all right moving on from the from
the coaches here you know the coach is
the job openings every year or five to
seven jobs and it also seems like
they're five to six teams every year
that didn't make the playoffs before
then make them the next year I mean
that's like death and taxes it happens
every year so five teams that missed the
playoffs last year the bills Packers
Viking Steelers 49ers would be in the
postseason if the season ended today
which one of those teams we're talking
to Albert Brewer from mmq be Dan Haley
filling in for Rich Eisen which one of
those teams Albert is the most
surprising to you right now 49ers 49ers
Steelers Vikings Packers and Bills Bills
actually like what they're building
their benefited from a really soft
schedule
yeah the Steelers are the ones face and
everything they've gone through it's a
great coach Mike Tomlin but this
offseason the drama losing Antonio Brown
was basically kind of like that that was
the first what two weeks or offseason at
the on what side a very very loud level
and then it sort of lingered for the
next two months before though obviously
like separating from Aviano I don't
happen to care about entering week two
you know they were sort of kinda I think
what's really interesting about it they
sort of had to like we imagine their
team I mean they thunks not offensively
17 for so long
and now I'm working with these guys and
they're sort of you know managing the
office a certain way where they're you
know it's one of almost like a like an
old horse cool funky motorcycle game and
so being able to sort changes you are on
the five journeys there's all of like
the sort of noise are on the team my tom
is going fantastic job and that was
something here at the end of the season
and the field are still alive despite
the fact that and you know a lot of
college football right good like if you
have a guy who I've never heard of at
the beginning here full disclosure
solely as a cornerback it really was on
call so I don't with the Steelers in
that way well I I don't think it's a
surprise Albert not many people have
heard of Devlin Hodges the state calling
champion from Alabama to be honest I had
neither plays his college ball at
Stanford all right let's go from most
surprising to most disappointing there's
a number of teams on this list you know
if you're in Cleveland certainly they
have to be one of the teams that you're
looking at you know the Falcons have not
lived up to expectations
the Chargers the charges are a team that
some people pick to go to the Super Bowl
and I mean they potentially could went
out to get to eight Nate and salvage a
semi respectable season but is there one
team that sticks out to you that you
thought would be playoff bound that's
now trying to figure things out yeah
cornerback you lost cackles that's gonna
have an effect you had to melt a gourd
holdout you have general and gingers
injury so I think it's a little easier
to explain that away like when I talk to
guys from other teams as the one that
sort of perplexed everybody inside the
league is the Falcons and it's a good
roster most of the people I know had a
lot of respect for Dan Quinn as a coach
he's able to get them to a suitable for
years ago and for one reason or another
just hasn't come together
the offensive line they did a lot of
work to try to fix with me Austin
Jackson is there in that urn but don't
look at where they are team wise
team that it is and so I'm saying if I
there
pick one seen as the most it's
disappointing at twenty nineteen eighty
two thousand some might even say the
Cowboys even though they're leading the
division at six and seven might be very
close to that list all right Albert I
know you're a big Ohio State guy chase
young
do you pass on all of these quarterbacks
and take him number one overall if
you're Cincinnati or do you have to get
a franchise quarterback with a number
one pick
I mean I guess also depends on your
valuations overall but I do this maybe
teams that are gonna be the top of the
traffic may be asking this question with
a couple of the prospect this case young
you know it could be like an Andrew
Thomas from tours of the offensive
tackle it could be you know Jeff Okuda a
number of guys I think that are gonna go
high in the drama 14 RBIs Ness question
and the reason why it doesn't relate as
much the prospects the position
prospects and this year's assets is
gonna be available in dexterous drafting
you know I could see like a Cincinnati
or Miami or one of these teams maybe
you're looking long-term and if you're
even a little lukewarm on Oboro do you
decide to press the pause button pick a
really good player in the top five and
then wait for Trevor Lawrence next year
so that could be like one of the most
interesting storylines on joining the
2020 draft you got a quarterback class
that's got potential there's some good
players there Joe Perot two tons of
Aloha
Justin Herbert but all these guys have
strings attached noburo sort of a
watching a guy purple it's a little raw
and hasn't really fulfilled as potential
yet no it's got the injuries obviously
so if you're one of these teams has got
a high pick do you sell yourself I
really like this defensive ender I
really like this corner I really like
this offensive tackle
let's just take him and wait and try to
get in position to take Trevor Lawrence
next year I think it's a very real
question it's going to be asking a lot
of buildings of a spray all right
quickly Albert get away question before
we let you go how far does to a fall no
until you like have all
medical information as of right now he
declares I think I I think he goes
somewhere in the middle to the bottom of
the first round and what's interesting
about to me is it's really it really
could be his benefit as he goes to like
say I'm doing under someone like that
where he'll have a chance to develop
super here developed and being in a good
environment a good winning if our that
could wind up being to his long-term
benefit you know that said I was since
I've gone through the history of
quarterbacks who come in to the week was
injured problems in the first round guys
we all have questions on coming in from
that regard in that regard almost all
who got hurt again and I go back to
Bradford 2010 Drinkwater in 2011
Rutherford in 2012 Marcus Mariota in
2015 Carson one for 2016 deshaun Watson
in 2017 all those guys had major
injuries in college and all of those
guys are that major injuries the pros
and so you know I think with two of the
questions going to be very much related
to as hell and it's not just one injury
he's had multiple ankle surgeries now
two in college and so right you know I
think almost entirely evaluation to is
going to come down to what the
individual teams doctors say and you
know right now I think that's still
doing much up in the air
Wow if we were paying you Albert I'd say
we got our money's worth with you today
I appreciate the time that was 24 solid
minutes of football content my friend
hey great to talk to you Albert have fun
the rest of the way hopefully we catch
up at the Super Bowl buddy all right
Albert Brewer from the mm QB Dan Haley
here filling in on their Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app